[Music]
hi
thank you for coming here in time and
agreeing to answer my 21 questions
and bringing me to your students house
today
well what did you have for breakfast
this morning
well i had to pour an all-nighter
yesterday because of my baby boy so
i just had instant noodles with bamboo
shoots
how do you usually travel to school i
travel to school on my scooter
which has been my means of
transportation for over six years
how long is your journey to school from
door to door
it's about five kilometer
yes that's not too far what's your
mindset when you enter the school
building every day
uh i just asked myself the question what
will the kids
learn from me today great
name one thing you love about the area
your school is in
uh that is about people who are ethnic
minority people
that's very honest kind and
hospitable yes i see who's your favorite
movie star
angelina jolie you know she is really
amazing
who's your favorite singer or your
favorite band
uh i am a devout fan of taylor swift
i really love her way she overcomes
difficulties in life
and challenges to succeed who's your
hero
my mom she is not only a mother
but a teacher a friend and a doctor
you are so lucky what's the one place
you would love to visit england that is
because
i'm teaching english so i really want to
experience
what i have learned and what i have
taught
from the textbook about people and
culture
and you know i love the culture which is
called
like uh safe uplift
what was your favorite subject in school
um english absolutely
the language i'm teaching now
i see what was your least favorite
subject at school
chemistry actually i was
very bad at chemistry what
i can remember about this subject is
that
what it consists of hydrogen and oxygen
what kind of student were you at school
a kind of
book one i was a very good student
without any boyfriend
what's your favorite food in the school
cafeteria
well in our school we do not have
cafeteria
but sometimes my students often bring
the specialties in the village and i do
love
seven color sticky rice which is made
from the different kinds of leaves in
the mountain
uh you know the surrounding mountains
here
what time do you usually leave school at
the end of the day
about 5 30 pm then i go back to my house
to take care of my baby boy
and i'm typically the first people to
come
to my school and the last to leave
do you usually keep working when you get
home
yep always wow you are hard working
what what do you do to relax well
playing with my little boy and swim in
the waterfall
somewhere very near here and you know
it's fantastic
what are your passions or hobbies
outside teaching
listening to music and reading
what's your proudest achievement as a
teacher
well that is not my prizes and
awards the proudest
achievement is that we are substantially
moving the learning barriers for ethnic
minorities
in the remote area then you know so far
we have
traveled over 40 countries so far
if you could write one motivational
quote on your blackboard
what would it be well
life have two rules number one
never give up number two remember number
one
that is my favorite quotation
what's the most important advice you
would give to your students
education is the most powerful weapon
for changing the world
and finally my last question why did you
become a teacher
when i was a little kid my mom brought
me to the village hall
to watch a movie named the mountainous
school
and the movie really sparked in me an
interest
to become the teacher that is because i
know the difficulties of poor educated
people and i really don't want them
to be kidnapped by a young man to be his
wife
or to be any uh kind of victims of
social evil
or any evil customs so for me
education is like the best channel
to change the world here so i really
want to become a teacher
wow that's such an inspirational story
thank you so much for answering my 21
questions